No matter what your goal is, you will
suffer to achieve it. So, pick a goal
that's big enough it's worth suffering
for. I'm Alex Ramoszi. I've been in
business 14 years. And just a few months
ago, I broke the world record for the
fastest selling non-fiction book in
history and generated over $105 million
in book sales within 72 hours. And I've
distilled everything I've learned from
that [music] experience and a decade of
building businesses into only lessons
that truly matter for achieving big
[music] ass goals. Starting with number
one, poor people suffer.
Rich people suffer, single people
suffer, married people suffer,
entrepreneurs suffer, employees suffer.
Suffering is a fixed cost of life. So
pick a life, pick a goal worth suffering
for. Your business will be painful when
it's shrinking. It will be painful when
it's plateauing. It will be painful when
it's growing. And so the biggest alpha
that we can generate as entrepreneurs or
as human beings is picking destinations
that we believe are meaningful enough
for us to get through the hard times.
Right? I think it was Victor Frank who
said a man who has a big enough why can
bear almost any how. Right? And so the
idea is that the how we know it's fixed.
It will suck. It will suck. And the
flavor of sucking will change. Sometimes
it will manifest as uncertainty. it will
come in because you don't know what you
have to do, but you have to take action
either way. You know, you have to do
something. You don't know what to do.
And so, you have this fixed cost that's
going that you will incur for taking
this action, for spending this money,
for making this bet, but the casino
table has odds that aren't
predetermined. You don't know if you put
on 32, you get 30x. If you put it on
red, you get you get double, right? You
don't know that. You don't know it. And
so, you basically just have to put your
shifts on the table and hope. And that
consistent process of making bets with
uncertain payoffs is incredibly painful.
It's almost the antithesis of what
allows you to survive. And so you have
to go against your human instinct of
surviving to make it through in
business. Because if you had that
instinct naturally, you'd say, "Oh,
these berries, I'm just going to go eat
them." And then you eat them. So
variable. And then you die. And then
your genes wouldn't proliferate. And so
the genes that we have are literally
meant for us to survive, not for us to
build big businesses because the entire
process is horrible. This ties directly
into something that I mentioned at the
start of this, which is that no matter
what your goal is, you will suffer in
order to achieve it. Right? So just pick
one that is big enough that it's worth
suffering for. The other part of that
pain, so one is uncertainty. Some of the
other pain is from outside people,
right? If you do nothing or you do
anything, people will criticize you.
They'll criticize you if you do nothing.
Like think about it if you ah he doesn't
do anything you'll get criticism if you
do anything they're like oh he's doing
it look how stupid it is people will
criticize you so the idea is do things
that it is worth being criticized for
you and to me pursuing goals my own
goals is worth being criticized for like
if you believe that you want to make
this difference make this change help
people out in some specific way I think
Alex Becker said this and I just love
this he's like you have to embrace the
cringe whenever you start at anything
you will suck and you will be
embarrassing you will look back at
yourself and you'll be embarrassed.
Think about how you were as a toddler.
Think about how embarrassing you are
probably to your parents or were to your
parents when you were a child learning
how to be a human. It doesn't mean that
being human and not living is not worth
doing. It just means that you have to go
through that phase. Big picture number
one is that the cost of the suffering is
fixed. And what's beautiful about that
is like what we're looking for is
arbitrage in the difference between our
suffering and what we get for it. But
the beauty is our suffering is
relatively fixed. Life is hard. But what
we get for our lives is what we get to
pick. And I think that's pretty cool.
Like we get to pick how big we want our
goals to be. And so this fixed cost,
like let's say someone says to you,
whatever your life savings is, whatever
the amount is, your life savings is a
lot of money to you. It's your life
savings. If someone says, I'm going to
take your life savings and you get one
thing. Wouldn't you make that one thing
worth giving your life savings for?
And so it's the same idea is that like
you your your cost is going to be
suffering. It's going to be uncertainty.
It's going to be criticism. It's going
to be mistakes. It's going to be
failures. It's going to be feeling
stupid. It's going to be looking cringe.
It's going to be being embarrassed.
That's your cost. And so the question is
most people trade it for a bag of chips.
They trade it for Netflix. They trade it
for for staying in on the weekend,
right? They stay it for they trade it
for for sleeping in. And that's why it
feels even worse because you traded your
life savings. You traded your life for
something that wasn't worth it. And so
we can't control this one, but we can
control this one. And I think that's the
value. So brings me my second thing. You
can beat 99% of people if you can master
the shame of rejection, the boredom of
repetition, and the pain of feedback.
You could be almost anyone at anything
if you're willing to fail 20 times in a
row, look stupid in front of people that
you care about and keep going long after
stopped being convenient. So, let me
unpack that for a second. In 20 hours,
most people can achieve a base level of
competence in just about any skill. And
that like that includes money-making
skills. That's what's crazy. Like you
want to learn sales, your first 20 hours
of sales, you will learn more about
sales than all of the videos and all the
books you've ever read because you have
so much more feedback because you're
actually doing it. That's the thing is
that you need feedback cycles to learn.
And learning for everyone, same
condition, new behavior. So if you watch
more videos, but your conditions are the
same and your behavior does not change,
you entertained yourself. You did not
educate yourself. Learning only
manifests with a change in behavior in
the same conditions. And so if you're
going to consume stuff, you have to act
on it in order for learning to occur.
And so I say this because as somebody
who once was a a entrepreneur who liked
to tickle my ears with different books
and self-help stuff, I realized one day,
this was when I was 21 or 22, I had read
like 14 self-help books over like a
quarter. And I was like, I'm going to
read a book a week, that whole thing,
right? And I realized at the end of the
14 books, I was in the same job, working
in the same city, and nothing in my life
had changed. And so I was like, well
then what was the outcome of those
books? What was the point of reading
them? And then I was like, oh, if I
don't do anything, nothing's going to
happen. And so then at that point, I
then vowed that the next book that I
read, I would do everything in the book.
And until I had done that, I wouldn't
read another book. And then I quit my
job and I drove across the country. And
then a lot of things changed, right? But
I say that because some of you guys are
in that boat, but it scales all the way
up. You can change your entire bloodline
the moment you realize that what you do
next always matters more than what you
did last. And so even though I had read
14 books in a row, it doesn't mean that
on my 15th book or your 15th book or
your 15th video or 500th video, that
what you choose to do after that can
literally change and can overcome can
supersede everything that came before
it. And I think if that's not an
inspiring message, I don't know what is.
And so I I saw this I saw this tweet the
other day by Chimp. So Chimp, what up?
Maybe you'll see this. But this is what
he or she said. The past nine years
feels entirely wasted to be honest. I
was 23. This year I turned 32. No job,
no wife, no kids, no generational wealth
like I promised myself that it would all
be worth it. I just fumbled my 20s
chasing imaginary numbers on the
internet. What the [__] So I read this
and I think I think it hit me when I was
I was scrolling on X
and the thing is is that like if you ask
high school seniors which of them
believes that they will be a millionaire
by 25 to over 50%. And to me that
demonstrates a huge amount of delusion.
people have no idea what it takes. And
to the same degree, the fact that
governments, you know, will give
$100,000, $200,000 loans to people
who've never made money in their lives
to earn a degree that has no earning
power anymore at all is unbelievably
irresponsible and arguably unethical
because you're talking to somebody who
barely barely has any life experience.
When I think about that last line of I
just fumbled my 20s chasing imaginary
numbers on the internet. I can promise
everybody who's listening to this that
in every realm of human endeavor there
is a significant amount of volume that
is required in order to unlock a new
skill. The amount of volume is different
by person. Some people learn fast, some
people learn slow, but everyone learns
eventually. And so if you want to take
the position that you will learn
eventually, no matter how bad your
genetics, no matter how bad your
upbringing is, which is the position
that I prefer because it's under your
control, then you just have to do so
much volume that it is unreasonable that
you fail. And so I see this and say like
I fumbled in my 20s chasing imaginary
numbers. To me, I hear that and I think
like you don't have a wife. How many
dates did you go on? Did you go on 10?
Did you go on a 100red? Did you go on
500? Now you might think to yourself,
wait, well I can't even get dates. Then
I would say, "Okay, how many girls did
you ask out? One a day? Five a day? 10 a
day? Well, oh, I I don't I don't leave
my house." Okay. How many times did you
leave your house a day? Right? Like all
of these things can be solved with
volume. And it's just that like it's
just people radically underestimate how
much how much how many how many
repetitions it takes to get good. Like
people saw the presentation that I gave
at the at the book launch and they're
like, "Oh, you know, Alex is such a
natural." Like if I've posted some of my
early videos. I do not sound natural
like this does not sound good. I do not
sound cool. I have I have virtually no
achievements to my name now at that
point. And so what one thing I will say
in terms of having some level of
confidence is this extrapolate your past
success of any kind to your next
success. So what does that mean? Like if
you were good at one subject in school,
then it's like, okay, if I was good at
that subject, then I can be good at all
the subjects. And then once you're good
at all the subjects, it's like, okay,
well, I did I did pretty well in that
grade, then I can do well in all the
grades. And then once you do well in all
the grades, then you you graduate,
you're like, you know, well, if I did
well in all the grades, I could probably
I could probably do well at at working
out and get in shape. I mean, there's no
reason I I could apply all that work
here and I can't apply that work here.
And then all of a sudden you're like,
well, you know, I'm not rich, but like
I'm in shape and I did well in school.
And so I can apply that work ethic and
that thinking of just doing repetitions,
doing the studying, doing the work that
I'll be able to figure out this new job
or I'll figure out this new role or I'll
figure out this new AI system, whatever
it is. And I I think I could apply that
to this. And so fundamentally, what
separates humans from other animals is
the ability to apply the transitive
property. If A equals B and B equals C,
then A equals C. That that transition is
what separates humans from everything
else on Earth. Just being able to say,
"Oh, then A equals C if A equals B and B
equals C." And so the idea is that we
have generalizable skills. You can learn
how to work hard at anything. And just
about everyone here has worked hard at
something. Maybe it was video games.
Maybe it was one particular course in
one particular year for one particular
teacher, but you have done something.
And the idea is to take that something
and say because I did it that time, I
can do it again. And to be able to
consistently apply that and then what
happens, you create this snowball until
eventually you you have this feeling
that you walk in a room and you're like,
I am inevitable. I may not get it the
first time, but I will [__] get it
because I will either die or I will
figure it out and I've got a lot of life
left to live. So, if you're under 30 and
you have no responsibilities, I
recommend working as many hours per week
as humanly possible because you will
never be able to work this hard again.
And the compounding effects of a few
years of hard work like this can set you
up for your life for decades. And this
is what I think people miss out on. It's
like we have this we have this
crescendo. We have this early part of
the skill gap. It's like why would we
not want to shovel as much towards that
as we can. Now listen, I want to be very
clear. If you want if you were like, I
love my life the way it is, then you
won. You're great. Like hallelujah. I'm
I'm like I'm on your team. You've
already won. Teach the world. All right.
But for everyone who's dissatisfied with
where you're at, and if you don't have
these responsibilities, if you're like,
well, I have three kids. It's like,
okay, then you have trade-offs. I mean,
straight up, you've got trades. But if
you don't have those responsibilities
and you do have the time and you do have
the energy and you were not happy with
where you are, or rather you would like
it to be better, your business to be
better, your career to be better,
whatever it is, why not give this time
and this energy because that is the time
you have it. You will never have fewer
responsibilities than you have now. And
I think it's it's worth digging the well
before you're thirsty because having to
do that later, not to say impossible,
just harder. And to be clear, some of
you guys are in that position. You're
like, "Dude, I got a wife and kids and
now I'm going to start my thing."
Amazing. It's going to be harder for
you. Here's the plus side. You got more
experience. So, you can be more
strategic with your effort. That's the
pro. You look at every, you know, pro
athlete, it's like by the end of their
careers, they're conserving their energy
better. They make the right, you know,
they strike at the right times. Their
their technique is better, right? But
they don't have the sheer power, they
don't have the sheer strength they had,
their quickness, the flexibility they
had in their in their youth. And that's
what expands people's careers because in
the youth like you don't have the
experience, you don't have the
technique, you don't have this, but but
you have all these other things and
that's what creates longer and it
changes how people fight, how people how
people do anything. And so every every
position has advantages and
disadvantages. And so I'll say this one
other point and then I'll move my next
point which is this. Every position on
the board has an advantage, right? If
you if you have nothing to lose,
then you have nothing to lose. If you're
like, I have nothing, it means you have
nothing to lose. I don't know how to say
that differently. And see, the idea that
you're like you were in the position
where you can literally take endless
unlimited lottery tickets from life,
which means you try and you try and you
try and you try because your downside is
zero. You have nothing to lose. And so
fear comes from having something to
lose. And so in order to be fearless,
we have to come to the realization that
nothing in this world belonged to you to
begin with. Like we're just passers by,
even if you accumulate whatever assets
you think you are. You just push your
chips back at the end of the game
anyways. And so like it's just the game.
And so you're somebody who has no chips.
But the one thing that's different about
poker versus real life is that the chips
you get get replenished every day with
the minutes of time that you have. And
so you could run out of chips, but you
still have time. Now, if you run out of
chips in the real life, out of coins,
right? Game over. But until that day,
you can play every day. And I think that
when you have a a capp downside, an
uncapped upside, that is the recipe for
opportunity. Which brings me to the next
point, which is that entrepreneurship is
one of the greatest vehicles of personal
development because I because it forces
you to confront every weakness that
you've been avoiding. The market, your
customers, your competitors won't let
you hide from yourself. And 10 out of 10
times, the person limiting the business,
limiting your growth is you. Real,
right? Like entrepreneurship. Like the
reason that I'm such a fan of this and
why I talk about it so much for people
who are, you know, in the game or not in
the game is that like the amount I've
grown as an entrepreneur versus when I
was not an entrepreneur, it pales in
comparison because people want to
protect your feelings, your friends,
your family, they don't want you to feel
bad. The market does not care. And if
you want truth, the market will will
give you the truth. And as long as you
can humble yourself and listen to the
market, it will tell you where you suck.
If I made content that no one's no one
liked, I would have to change, right?
I'd have to change what I was doing. And
if you make products that no one wants
to buy, you have to change what you're
doing. If when you get in front of
somebody and no one wants to buy, you
have to change what you're saying.
Period. But if you go and do that in
front of your mom, she's going to be
like, "Great job, Timmy. I It was really
good. Really good. Great job." So it
just fluffs you. It's not real. And so I
think that over time, what happens is
people end up optimizing towards real
reality, truth. And I think
entrepreneurship is one of the best
vehicles for that. So one of the next
issues is that like most people think
the hard part is getting started. But
the hard part is continuing to do the
work when the excitement wears off and
the grind, the repetitions, the volume
without variety feels hopeless. Your
inability to work without reward for an
extended period of time will hurt your
potential far more than your lack of
talent. Real. Because the most dangerous
person in the world is the one who
continues to show up every day, even
when the rewards are not guaranteed.
Your potential is determined by the
amount of uncertainty that you're able
to tolerate and how long you can
tolerate it for. This is what people
miss. Like if you want to be dangerous
in any domain, your potential is
determined by how much uncertainty that
you can tolerate, how much can you deal
with, how much can you take, and how
long you can take it for. So Sam Alman
said this from OpenAI. He said, "I still
think one of the last alphas that exists
in terms of the superior return on
effort is long-term thinking." He said,
"Because so few people are willing to do
it." actually think in terms of one
year, five years, 10 years. Most people
can't. And I get that you can't have a
vision if you have bills to pay, if rent
is due. I understand that. And so this
is why I'm such an advocate of like get
yourself out of the hole as fast as
humanly possible. Like do whatever you
got to do to get your oxygen mask on.
Work three jobs, right? Do your main
thing, get your side thing going, right?
do whatever it takes so that you can get
above that. Just get your head above
water. At that point, options open up.
And so, one of the difficult parts of of
of living in general, and so somebody
asked for a definition, I'll give you
one, is that if you feel sad right now,
it's because sadness comes from a
perceived lack of options.
It's why it feels so hopeless. Because
you don't know what to do. And typically
you don't know what to do because you
have defined rules that you arbitrarily
have chosen to live by. You have seen
consequences that are bearable as
unbearable. I could never say that to my
parents. I could never leave my friends.
I could never leave this city. You say
these nevers, these absolutes. It would
be impossible for me. But of course,
that's not true. What it really means is
that you are unwilling to make a trade.
When you are sad or you feel bad about
your existing circumstance, the question
to ask is, "What trade am I knowingly or
unknowingly unwilling to make?"
Because there are always more options. I
think Harvey from Suits, who's like the
big the big lawyer, he says, "Someone
points a gun in your face. What do you
do?" He says it to his mentee. I think
his name is Mike. And he says, "I don't
know. you just, you know, do what they
tell you to do. He said, "No." He's
like, "There's a hundred things that you
can do." He's like, "You can grab the
gun. You can shout. You can ask for
help." He's like, "There's a hundred
things that you can do, but sadness
comes from the perceived lack of
options, not lack of options. From the
perceived lack of options."
And so, the big the big point here is
that you can create options for yourself
by changing the trades that you're
willing to make. being willing to
tolerate things that you were beforehand
unwilling to tolerate. I try to share
the things that have helped me and
and I get a lot of messages when I talk
about that stuff, but I also get the
amount of just like victimhood. It it
it's it spikes with anything related to
that stuff. I say this as someone who
had a family who struggled with mental
health. I wholeheartedly understand the
struggle and I share this because it is
what helped me and like when I talk
about options like the perceived lack of
options like when I am sad and I get sad
and I think part of that is genetic I
think to myself like what trades am I
unwilling to make what what
impossibilities am I claiming are
impossible but aren't and then what is
the consequence of that because fear
only exists in the vague not in the
specific specific. And so when I want to
walk myself down an uncomfortable path,
I start playing out, but no, no, what
would it really look like? Okay, let's
say I I could never disappoint my
parents. No, no, but what would it
really look like? I would go there and I
would say I was leaving and then what
would happen? They would block me and
I'd have to physically fight them to get
out of the house. Okay, am I willing to
do that or die? Well, I'd prefer to stay
alive and so I'll do that. And if I had
to fight them, I would fight my way out.
Okay. But assuming they didn't want to
have a physical altercation with me,
what then would happen? Well, they
probably wouldn't talk to me. Okay.
Well, there's probably been times in my
life where that was a nice thing. Okay.
So, maybe that's not so bad. What else
would happen? You wouldn't be able to
come home for holidays. It's not so bad
either. I mean, I can I can eat I can do
a Friendsgiving instead of a
Thanksgiving. Like Christmas I could
celebrate elsewhere. That's not a huge
deal. Oh, okay. He's like, "Okay, so the
cost of my dreams is not getting texts
from my parents and not being able to
have specific foods on specific days of
the year. That's what I'm what I'm
willing to suffer. That's what I'm what
I'm unwilling to trade. That terrible
experience." And I think when we frame
those things in the specific, all of a
sudden these fears we have around the
decisions, the actions we know we need
to take but aren't all of a sudden begin
to melt away. And I think that is where
the chains we put on ourselves get
broken. People underestimate how much
effort it takes to stick with one thing
rather than jumping to the next shiny
opportunity every six months. The price
of wanting to be good at everything is
being good at nothing. This happens at
all stages in business. So being good at
everything versus being good at nothing.
Typically, you could think about that as
a business owner in terms of the number
of services, the number of products that
you try to provide, the number of SKUs,
because you're like, well, they want
this, well, they want this or they want
this. The thing is is that if you give
customers everything they want, they
will create their own demise. Nobody
wants a thing that has everything. It
doesn't work. Right? This is where
simplicity, this is where design, this
is where elegance, this is where
removing friction. All of the these
things matter. But they are strategies.
They are decisions. And decisions comes
from the Latin which means dicadere,
which means to cut off, which means
which path do we remove when we make
decisions. And when people are afraid of
making decisions, they say yes to
everything because they're so afraid of
saying no. And so the effort that it
takes to compound is the length of time
you have to say no to everything else.
It is the paths untaken. The opportunity
that you believe in your mind
imaginarily that you are missing out on
is the price of getting good at any one
thing. And most people can't succeed on
whatever they're going for if you just
give it six months. 100 days. That's
less than six months. But if you just
did one thing for that period of time,
you'd be amazed at what can happen.
There is a company that is beating Y
Combinator in terms of its returns. It's
called HFZ. They've like tripled Y
Combinator's returns. Let me tell you
their operating model. So, first off, of
course, they've got a lot of founders
that that that apply because they now
have reputation, but I think something
in the neighborhood of they promise like
the average company that like 70% of
their companies get to 2 million in ARR
within 12 weeks, which is pretty crazy,
right? 70% very high success rate. So,
how are they able to do this? This is
what they've operationalized. They
operationalize putting someone in a hole
and not letting anything bother them.
So, this is a residence. People fly out.
Founders fly out. They go in these
windowless rooms in the basement and
they take care of literally everything
that the founder has and they remove
every distraction. And so, the only
thing that they have to confront is the
work in front of them. And so what they
have found is that the compounding
effect of having full context of big
hard problems in your head where you
don't have to switch contexts because
you have to take a call or do a meeting
or someone says something mean to you
online where you actually can just wade
through and swim through these complex
problems. The compounding returns that
comes from that time of uninterrupted
flow. That is where huge amounts of
value get created. And it is impossible
to do that if every six months you
change your mind. You get lucky by
staying in the game long enough for luck
to find you. You cannot beat someone who
has already decided that they will do
whatever it takes for as long as it
takes. And so that person, if anyone
could do it, it might as well be you. At
least that is how I think through these
things because there's there's really
only one belief that you need to win,
which is belief in your ability to
figure it out. That's it. Start and
you'll figure out the rest because
sometimes you have to be the only one
who believes in you. And we are rewarded
as entrepreneurs and human beings for
believing in ourselves more than other
people do. Like that is that is the gift
that we get and that is why
entrepreneurs earn disproportionately
more than others. And not all
entrepreneurs that in fact the vast
majority of entrepreneurs make less.
But there are a select few entrepreneurs
who make significantly more. And it's
because they were able to stick with the
uncommon path for an extended period of
time long after it made sense reasonably
for them to stop said no to imaginary
opportunities in their minds and were
willing to make trades that other people
were not. And so right now everything
that we want in our lives is a few
trades away from where we currently are.
It's just that the trades that we have
to make are trades that are so deeply
embedded in our belief system that we
don't even see them as possibilities.
And so one of my favorite quotes of all
time comes from Orson Scott Card. He's
the he's the writer of Enders Game. This
is my adaptation so paraphrasing. We
question all of our beliefs except for
those that we truly believe and those we
never think to question. And so the
reason that sadness is a perceived lack
of options is means that we have beliefs
that we are that are so deeply ingrained
in us that we aren't even cognizant. We
are not even conscious of the fact that
we believe these things so deeply
because they are so embedded in our
reality that we cannot see reality
without them. And this is why like a
great amount of my time has been
dedicated to defining terms and defining
words so that I could try and see
reality more clearly. And I think that
if you see someone who's able to
consistently get what they want, it's
because they're able to make better
trades or better bets than you are. And
so it is always worth learning from
anyone who gets what they want because
you can model aspects of their behavior
and then more importantly aspects of the
weights that they put on decision-m to
predict outcomes.
Because the better you get at that, the
more you get what you want. And if you
don't have what you want, then that is
the skill deficiency is that you do not
see reality as it is. You see reality as
you want it to be, which is not reality.
It is distortion. I'll leave you guys
with that. That is my that is my two
cents on uh on some of the hard the
hardness of getting where you want to
go. Um, and hopefully that was that was
helpful for at least one